ladies and gentlemen
Russia's Invasion has brought
unspeakable suffering to Ukraine
almost one year ago the world discovered
the horrors of butcher
I was there myself and I have witnessed
the atrocities committed by Russian
forces
there is increasing evidence of direct
attacks against civilians as well as on
energy and other infrastructure
torture
ill treatment
sexual violence
and summary executions are known to have
been committed by Russian forces not
even children are being spared
Russia must be held accountable for
these horrific crimes and Putin must be
held accountable
we must do everything in our power
to bring the perpetrators to Justice
the European Union is supportive of the
role of the international criminal court
we also believe that there needs to be a
dedicated tribunal to prosecute Russia's
crime of aggression
and I'm proud that at this conference as
a first step you will sign the agreement
to set up the International Center for
prosecution of the crime of aggression
in The Hague
the European Union will continue to work
with our partners to ensure that Russia
pays
We Stand United for justice for Ukraine